es rockt da fühlt man sich oft
unbesiegbar sowie sah man von den hells
angels in köln wird er aber jetzt für
vogelfrei erklärt
und damit ist er auf der todesliste
seines ehemaligen arbeitgebers in der
nacht zum vergangenen samstag der
anschlag unbekannte lauern dem rocker im
kölner kunibert viertel auf als er sein
haus verlässt wird aus einem fahrenden
auto auf ihn geschossen mindestens
dreimal die kugeln schlagen durch
autoscheiben und durch eine gläserne
eingangstür querschläger peitschen durch
die nacht sah man b kann im letzten
moment und ein parkendes auto springen
rettet somit sein leben
was war passiert wir fast für sie die
geschehnisse noch einmal zusammen
jahrelang soll der 31-jährige some anbeh
der geldeintreiber der bande gewesen
sein es ging um drogenhandel
prostitution und andere schmutzige
geschäfte doch das ist geschichte der
käfigkämpfer soll den clan verlassen
haben postet anschließend videos im
internet in denen er sich mit seinem ex
rocker boss fatih k anlegt das besiegelt
sein todesurteil
ich habe so viel über dich material ich
hab so viel fundiert wenn ich einmal
über die stinken würde würdest du nie
wieder aus diesem talent kommt fatih k
erklärt hamann b als vogelfrei als out
im bett standing das bedeutet im rocker
kodex jedes andere hells angels mitglied
darf den ausgestoßenen töten vor zwei
wochen lauern bereits zehn bis fünfzehn
rocker dem 31 jährigen auf und greifen
ihn an
die attacke schlägt fehl hamann b
überlegt
wir beschäftigen uns mit unseren
experten mit diesem jahr neuen krieg im
hells angels rocker milieu das machen
wir mit unserem kreis chefreporter frank
schneider der ja die rockerszene seit
langem kennt vor allen dingen natürlich
in nordrhein-westfalen in seiner heimat
und mit christian mazda auf dem
professor für kriminalistik und
langjährigem kripo ermittler euch beiden
ihnen beiden schönen guten morgen
frank lasst uns doch einmal reinkommen
in diesem fall ganz kurz für unsere
zuschauer was ist das für ein fall was
ist das für eine rocker auf denen die
jetzt geschossen wurde
ja es handelt sich um ein mitglied der
hells angels in köln und er ist eben bei
den hells angels rausgeflogen eigentlich
hatte die hells angels selbst im streit
verlassen ist dann aber in so genannte
auch im bett standing erklärt worden man
muss da vielleicht einmal die rocker
sprache erklären dieses out heißt eben
raus und in bed standing eben im
schlechten getrennt und im bösen
getrennt und das ist bei den rockern
schon etwas ganz elementares denn wer
ein auto im bett standing ist der darf
als von jedem anderen hells angel
angegriffen verletzt sogar getötet
werden und das hat ja hier auch genauso
angefangen erst kam ein rollkommando von
circa zehn bis 15 personen hat versucht
ihn anzugreifen jetzt ist er aber selber
kampfsportler extrem kräftig das sehen
wir auch auf den bildern und extrem gut
so zu sagen wie er sich wehren kann ja
und dann ist man vermutlich wir wissen
es ja nicht der täter ist ja noch nicht
gefasst die polizei ermittelt noch gegen
unbekannt ist man offenbar zu anderen
mitteln übergegangen und hat dann auf
ihn gefeuert und was man noch mal sagen
muss wir haben sie eben schon gehört die
kugeln schlugen in ein auto ein in die
gläserne türen hätte auch jemand hinter
stehen können und eine cool ist wirklich
durch ein fenster in eine wohnung eines
unbeteiligten eingeschlagen und ist dann
in die musikbox geprallt des dortigen
mieters der nur wenige zentimeter
daneben schlief also man muss sagen das
zeigt eben auch es ist keine abrechnung
untereinander die nehmen da einfach eben
auch kollateralschäden tod von
unbeteiligten schlimme schäden einfach
in kauf und das ist natürlich eine
situation die kölner polizei so nicht
weiter mit anschauen kann die arbeiten
jetzt mit hochdruck daran neben diesen
täter zu fassen eben diesen krieg zu
befrieden bevor es wirklich noch tote
gibt bevor es noch tote gibt sagte unser
chefreporter frank schneider r matzdorf
aussteigen aus dem hells angels aus dem
rockermilieu funktioniert also nicht
mann schwebt dann automatisch in
lebensgefahr
im rockermilieu ist ein kodex sozusagen
die eigenen regeln die man sich dort
gegeben hat man ist wenn man rocker wird
einer entsprechenden gruppierung
angehört dann auf lebenszeit angehörige
gruppierung im prinzip noch über das
leben hinaus tod wird eine grabpflege
oder ähnliches dann gearbeitet das heißt
man kann diese gemeinschaft nicht mehr
alleine freiwillig auf eigenen beschluss
verlassen verlässt man sie doch dann ist
man eben in der situation die wir hier
gerade von den kollegen geschrieben
bekommen haben dann ist man
möglicherweise aus geschmissen worden
outstanding und man wird sozusagen für
vogelfrei erklärt und ist dann in
lebensgefahr
jetzt gibt es ein video von es sah man b
das fand ich immer gemeinsam analysieren
wir schon mal rein
guck mal ich kenne dich ich war über
zehn jahre neben der tagung macht ja ich
will
meine schublade ist nun behaupte ich bin
ein linker weißt du was der beste beweis
dafür ist dass ich keiner bin ich habe
so viel über dich material ich habe so
viel von dir wenn ich einmal über die
stinken würde würdest du nie wieder aus
diesem zelle rauskommen die würden dich
anschließend absperren für immer am
schlüssel wegschmeißen ja was laberst du
für ein müll ja was für zecken jeder
kennt mich in köln jeder kennt mich in
nrw ich mach mich gerade ich mache ich
bin ein straßenköter faktisch macht auf
der straße geraten und weiß jeder du
weißt es am allerbesten ja du willst
mich im knast haben ich dich nicht im
knast aufgestoßen also dieses video
gerichtet an den chef der hells angels
quasi an seinen früheren arbeitgeber
frank hilf uns ein bisschen bei der
einordnung und übersetzung was will und
sah man will damit sagen
na ja das ist ja eine unverhohlene
drohung er sagt mir ganz klar wenn du
nicht aufhörst nicht zu verfolgen dann
packe ich aus und er war seine rechte
hand das ist das katana field nach
übersetzt frei übersetzt nach dem
begriff ehrenfeld nämlich ein stadtteil
in köln köln ehrenfeld und
deshalb war die rechte hand von diesem
partie man muss natürlich mal sagen es
gilt die unschuldsvermutung keiner weiß
ob der wirklich hinter diesem mord
auftrag hinter diesen schlüssen jetzt
steckt die vermutung liegt natürlich
nahe auch bei der polizei aber wie
gesagt noch wird gegen unbekannt
ermittelt das ist doch noch mal wichtig
an dieser stelle zu sagen aber dieser
dieser krieg ist da dieser streit ist da
soll um gelder gehen ist soll um
schutzgeld erpressung um prostitution
und drogen gehen und eben diesen geldern
daraus und das sagt er in dem video ich
habe die schublade voll wie er es nennt
er hat also sozusagen beweise gegen ihn
und wenn er auspackt er nennt das
jahrzehnten wenn er auspackt dann sitzt
er für immer hinter gittern und das ist
natürlich eine unverhohlene drohung da
sind dann durch ein an einer ganz
anderen stelle da geht es nicht nur
darum dass er eben den outstanding ist
und sozusagen vogelfrei erklärt ist
jeder ihn angreifen darf er geht jetzt
in die gegenoffensive und droht
unverhohlen seinem ehemaligen rocker
boss und drohte ihm eben auch
auszupacken und lebenslang knast in den
knast zu wandern und das ist natürlich
eine eskalationsstufe wie wir jetzt
sehen die dann mit schüssen beendet ist
zum glück ohne folgen aber das ding ist
noch nicht zu ende wie man so zu sagen
pflegt und man muss natürlich auch sagen
er lebt jetzt erstmal untergetaucht wild
yam anteil wohl nicht so richtig von der
polizei schützen lassen das tut man eben
als rocker nicht sah man empfindet sich
ja immer noch irgendwo auch als rocker
und ja es ist für die polizei eine
relativ schwierige situation weil man
natürlich in der szene auch mit der
polizei nicht redet es gibt dieses
gesetz des schweigens genau wie man das
aufheben von der mafia kennt wir haben
es eben von dem polizisten gehört es ist
ebenso es ist eine familie es gibt
diesen diese abkürzung apa das heißt
eben angel forever forever angel und da
ist man eben für immer drin das ist wie
familie verlässt seine familie nicht du
gehst nicht selber und das ist ein
riesenproblem wie sich das wie man das
auflösen kann ist mir eigentlich gesagt
ein und vielleicht auch noch ein
wichtiger hinweis die polizei hat das ja
gewusst oder wenn du fährst gewusst hat
befürchtet dass es dort zu extremen
eskalationen kommen kann sie haben eine
sogenannte gefährderansprache
durchgeführt bei dem rocker boss und
seinen leuten haben auch den zimmern
gewarnt und trotzdem ist das eben
passiert das zeigt wir sind auf eine
eskalationsstufe wo denen wirklich egal
ist was sagt die polizei drohen
unbeteiligte opfer das scheint momentan
alles egal zu sein und wir hatten solche
zeiten schon mal reale
nordrhein-westfalen rockerkrieg da wurde
jede woche geschossener flogen
handgranaten das möchte die polizei
natürlich um jeden preis vermeiden dass
so etwas wieder entsteht jetzt spricht
hier so viel über die regeln die dort in
diesem milieu herrschen aber wir haben
ja hier auch unsere regeln im
rechtsstaat das heißt jetzt ganz naiv
müsste sich die polizei den sah man doch
schnappen und müsste sagen kommt also
wir geben dir schutz aber du packst halt
hier richtig aus du trost nicht damit
sondern du legst jetzt mal deine beweise
auf den tisch du machst deine schublade
mal auf also welche möglichkeiten
hermsdorf hat die polizei tatsächlich um
das was jetzt naiv einmal formuliert
habe tatsächlich durchzusetzen
die polizei muss sich natürlich an recht
und gesetz halten das heißt wir müssen
davon ausgehen so lange nichts bewiesen
ist dass es ja eine unschuldsvermutung
gibt gegenüber linien die wir hier als
auftraggeber erwarten was den dass ihm
drohten man hier an geht er kann
natürlich gebrauch machen von einer
regelung der gesetzgeber vorgesehen hat
der sogenannten kronzeugen regelung das
heißt er kann sich dem schutz des
staates versichern und möglicherweise
für eine strafmilderung für begangene
straftaten hoffen wenn das von der
justiz entsprechend so bewertet wird das
ist eine theoretische möglichkeit die
praxis sieht anders aus hier geht es um
knallharte geschäfte und nichts anderes
die begriffe von moral ihre und familie
verbringen das immer nur es geht hier um
geschäft es geht um geld macht und
einfluss und den möchte man sich sichern
und offensichtlich sind hier zwei männer
aneinander geraten die genau auf diesen
konflikt fällt nämlich geschäfte machen
hier offensichtlich nicht mehr einer
meinung sind
dank hermannsdorf danke frank ganz
kurzer satz am ende
du betrachtest beobachtest diese klaren
diese rocker fälle seit langer langer
zeit wer setzt sich da mehr durch die
rocker oder der start der innenminister
na ja zum glück immer am ende des tages
dann doch irgendwo der staat ist wächst
natürlich immer etwas nach wir kennen
den fall noch vielleicht ganz schnell
gesagt der holland rocker der sahara
rocker damals dort hat nachher der
rocker präsident selber ausgepackt als
kronzeuge vor gericht er lebt bis heute
versteckt er hat versteckt oder sagen
wir mal verdeckt im gefängnis gesessen
seine familie ist immer noch im
zeugenschutz der hat das damals für sich
genutzt und und recht das noch mal
abzuschließen zu dem wort meines
vorredners das problem ist die
grundsanierung gibt aber dann ist ihm
klar er kann sein leben so nicht mehr
weiter führen er wird auch trotzdem ins
gefängnis bekommen er wird ja nicht frei
gesprochen denn er war die rechte hand
von dem rocker präsidenten er weiß eben
was alles war sagt er selber du weißt es
am besten ich war neben dir und er würde
sich ja dann selber eben von straftaten
schuldig machen und da gibt es mal eben
im deutschen gesetz auch die möglichkeit
das zeugnisverweigerungsrecht wenn ich
mich selber von straftaten belaste muss
ich nicht aussagen und das macht es halt
so schwierig danke frank schneider
unseren chefreporter danke herr matzdorf
für diese einschätzung in nach nordrhein
westfalen wo ein neuer rockerkrieg droht